- On this episode, I come
back solo, with thunder.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them
This is
The #AskGaryVeeShow.
- Hi everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 216
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
A little post 4th of July Show.
It's weird, I'm not
even sure the last time
I did an episode where
there wasn't another
human being with me,
in the office,
very much like out
of sync and excited
to get back into sync
Facebook Live.
Our team has like
tripled since we've been,
right, like we have all
these new characters.
Sid the intern's back.
India is away, so Britt,
you're gonna have to be ready
to play that role.
- Alright.
- Alright, so that's
good, you had a good 4th?
Nice, you guys?
All good stuff?
DRock, great, awesome.
Alright, I'm super excited
with what's been going on
in the last month,
it's all good stuff.
Been traveling a lot,
running VaynerMedia,
a lot going on.
Obviously a lot of guests,
which has been fun,
but I'd be lying if I didn't
say that I was super excited
to get back into the
rhythm of just you and I.
Especially because
people really hate
the way I interview people,
because as one,
but I will like to say,
as one person emailed me,
it was a psychologist,
my brain works too
fast according to her,
and since I already know what
the other person is saying
I'm not patient enough
to let it come through,
but I'm not doing a good
enough job projecting that
your guy's brains don't
work as fast as mine.
I was dying when
I got that email.
It was like, that's the best,
I'm gonna start using that.
Like guys, I'm sorry,
my brain's too fast,
but no question, I get hyper
when the guests are here.
So I apologize for
all of you that hate
when I interrupt the
guests, but we don't edit,
Staphon, I really think
that's what it is.
I feel the pressure of not editing,
whereas when I'm on
shows and I'm on
for fucking 53 minutes,
and it becomes
a 27 minute podcast, it's easy,
all my rambling or
whatever they didn't like,
they get to edit.
These guys ramble,
and they're promoting.
And that's not
bringing you any value.
So you're mad at me for
trying to make the show
good for you.
Do you agree?
- Oh, I completely agree.
- Of course, now they're
all gonna say
you have to agree.
I saw that too.
- [Britt] That's not true.
I know that
'cause you know me,
but DRock did you see the
bus episode of DailyVee?
They're like,
oh Gary's not that funny,
everybody has to laugh.
I'm like, dude, I'm super funny.
- [DRock] We all had a laugh there.
- Right, then you laugh forcibly.
- [Britt] I'm nervous you're
gonna ask me to get into
the show and then--
- No, that's me and India,
I'm not,
we'll have to talk
about our own thing.
Alright, let's do this.
- [Voiceover] Earthwalker
asks, do you have a shit list?
People, organizations you
won't work with
for whatever reason?
- That's an interesting question.
You know and actually,
one thing I promised myself
on my comeback trail,
here in episode 216 is I'm
gonna answer these questions
not just kind of
literally, black and white,
but I'm gonna really
challenge myself.
I think the golden
eras of the show
was when I could
answer the question,
but also then know how to bring
value to the whole audience
and I, right off the bat,
came in hot, I'm excited.
Which is, I don't and
now let's talk about it.
I truly believe that
anybody who has a shit list
has a vulnerability.
Because when you're
using negativity
to drive your success,
I think that's a problem.
To me, spending
any energy and time,
with a list of people I don't
wanna do business with
or put out of business, or
negative, or like people
that got me and
I'm gonna get them back,
I think is insane.
It's stunning to me, looking
back at my 20 year career.
There was a guy that I went
to a wine tasting of,
went to the wine tasting in
New York City at the Hilton.
The Wine Spectator
National Wine Tasting,
all the best wineries are there.
I came in, and I come,
and I go to this winery,
and they have this great
Shiraz, Australian wines
are getting super hot, and I'm
like selling a lot of them,
more than anybody
in the country.
And I come and I'd like
to taste your wine,
thinking this guy was
going to react really well
because we sold a ton of it.
He goes into a curse
laden, I'm a piece of crap.
And I've never lad this
happen to me in life.
Like just drilled me.
You're the devil of the
industry, I hate you.
Like nasty, nasty, nasty stuff.
And it was because
I was selling his wine
at the most aggressive
price in the country
and he thought
I was killing his brand,
meanwhile, there were 30
other stores selling it
for that price, but he hadn't
been on top of technology yet
and didn't know there was
a site called Wine-Searcher
that allowed you to see
every price on the internet,
and I was just matching the
best price in the country.
But because I was
the biggest guy,
when I emailed it
and promoted it,
all the other stores that
were selling it for more
called and complained.
He did no homework,
he was immature,
he was very hot at the time so
he had the audacity and ego.
Needless to say, the
Australian wines got less hot,
over the next five years,
and then that coincided with
Wine Library TV's explosion,
and then this guy who said I
was the devil of the industry
and the worst piece of
crap, and a loser kid
and was never going
to amount to anything,
emailed me, five years
later, begging for me to be
on the show for
exposure for his wine.
And with no hesitation
I said yes.
I believe being the bigger man.
I believe not holding grudges.
I believe that one of the
reasons I'm successful in life,
let alone business is I don't
allow poison or negativity
to be stored within my confines,
and I think it's a very big thing.
I've been talking a
lot more about optimism
and positivity being
a real factor,
I'm starting to get
a little more zen
in my older age, and
I believe that if you have
a shit list, if you have a list,
if you hold a grudge, you're
coming at your own expense.
That you're not doing
anything, do I forget?
No.
But it's just context,
it doesn't mean I'm going
to get you with it, it just
means I have to navigate
around it, and that's
a very big difference.
I don't wanna stick it to you.
I just need to navigate
around your truth
and there might be
some negativity there,
and I wanna get around it.
I don't wanna walk into your
cancer over and over again,
punch in the face either.
So, I would highly
recommend for all of you,
If I can do anything
with this episode,
if this becomes the
moment in your life
where you stop thinking
having a shit list.
By the way, so many people
in my family love that.
They love the grudge list,
Eastern European old school,
we're gonna get them,
we're gonna stick it
to them in the end.
I think the positivity
and the winning.
I think nothing sticks it to
anybody better than results.
Instead of tearing them down,
just get so God damned big
that that's the ultimate
I got you back.
And that comes
through positivity.
How are they liking
it on Facebook?
- [Haris] Love it.
- What are you talking about,
you just looked at
it in one second.
You could have
only seen like two.
I know how Facebook Live works.
- I've been watching it.
As you're talking, I'm watching it.
- I thought you were
more mesmerized by the.
Say hello, you haven't even said,
Have you said hello yet?
- Hello Vayner Nation,
I'm Haris, the new intern.
On ask.
- [Gary] How do you spell it.
- H-A-R-I-S.
Not Harris.
- Not Harris, not Horace,
like Horace Grant,
you son of a bitch.
He was a Bull.
I hate the Bulls.
Speaking of Bulls,
Derrick Rose and J. Noah,
who's gonna be my favorite
Knick because that just like,
the way he plays.
I tweeted like, Noah is literally
my least favorite player,
which means he's going
to be my favorite player
now that he's on my team.
- [Britt] You ready?
- Always.
- [Voiceover] Caleb asks,
"Would you work a nine to five
"for all of 2017 if it
meant you would own the
"New York Jets on
January 1st of 2018?"
- Yes.
- [Britt] 100%.
- Yes, I mean.
You know, now trying
to challenge myself
to make these good questions.
You know, I'll take it here.
Anybody who's not
willing to do something
that they hate so
much in the short term
to have what they love
so much in the long term
is usually the blue print of a person
that is normally not winning.
One of the biggest
separations between me
and a lot of people watching this
and other people that are
successful in your life.
If you're not, or vice versa,
you the successful person
and the people that
are think you're lucky
or curious to why
you are winning
is that most winners tend
to have much more patience
than their contemporaries.
I don't need anything now,
and most of the people do.
Most people are such
consumers in the US world.
They want stuff.
They want the new iPad.
They want the new jeans,
they want the new kicks.
They want the vacation,
you know, they want stuff,
and social media, where
everybody's PR'ing their best life
and showing them the new car.
I mean this weekend,
everybody is showing
you the best barbecue that
they've ever been to, right?
It makes people have FOMO
and really aspire to more,
and I'm kind of the other way.
Like I've just never wanted
those kind of things.
I'm not affected by, I'm happy
for other people's glory,
not asking why I don't have that
or compare myself to that.
I'm in my own zone and I'm
very, very, very patient
so I would eat crap.
How about this, I would work
a nine to five for the next
10 years if you told me
I owned the New York Jets
on the next day after
that, how about that one?
15.
20.
I would work every day,
nine to five,
for the next 20 years, if
you told me at 61 years old
I owned the New York Jets.
30.
I would work every single day,
nine to five for a corporation
for the next 30 years
to own the New York Jets.
It wouldn't happen, because
that's not how it's,
how it works.
But I would, I would.
Because by the way, you
know how much hustle
I would do from seven pm
until two in the morning?
Like nine to five is cake.
Like you guys know that
that's a half a day.
That's a half a day!
That's like right,
that's the other part
I don't think people understand.
I literally work 18 hours
a day, 15 hours a day.
Like working nine to five,
like that would be amazing.
I'd play basketball every
morning and work out,
and work and then work and then
hang out with my family too.
That would be insane.
40 years.
- [Voiceover] George asks,
"I'm curious to see where
grandmavee is headed.
"Seems to be getting
a lot of traction.
"Are you going to
make it a thing?"
- For all of you that
missed Grandma Vee
over I guess Wednesday
and Thursday of last week.
There was a filter on
Snapchat, I went into character
called Grandma Vee, grannyvee.
I converted it to grannyvee
because it's just better.
And you know, she was
just, basically it was just
really funny about it, she
was just basically saying
the same things I say
except it's funny.
I think of myself
as an old soul,
and it just makes more sense.
Basically, she, I just made videos
on Snapchat where
she said, in my day,
and then basically said
the things I believe in.
And it was a lot of fun,
and boy did it catch fire.
People really
passionate about it.
Unfortunate the granny
filter is gone now,
and I dunno if they're
bringing it back so.
I don't know where it's going.
I guess we could design it.
I guess Andrew could just draw it
and we could put it
over my head at times.
I do think I should
do a grannyvee episode
of The AskGrannyVee Show.
I'm super willing to do it if
Andrew is willing to draw it
and impose it, you guys
can figure it out, team.
I will do a
whole episode, in costume.
One little fun fact, Staphon,
you forget these edits
sometimes, even still,
so do not miss this one.
This is not the first time
I went into character.
Way back in the day,
during Wine Library TV,
there was a character
called Sir Gary Vaynerchuk,
which was the classic,
more serious wine reviewer.
Staphon, give them
30 seconds right now.
- The key to everything is this.
Gary is in Hungary, and
it is now the Friday show.
Now obviously he could
not do this on Monday
because it was raining,
and it was a Monday.
And how could you possibly
do a Friday show on Friday.
So I threw the couch out the window,
and I jumped in and I've
taken over the show today.
He's not here, call it
a Coup d'etat for you.
- So I've been known
to do this before,
and it has inspired me to
consider going into character
on Snapchat filters more often
'cause I think
it's interesting content,
I think I can pull it off,
and I think it's a blue
print for a lot of you.
I think a lot of you
that are struggling
that are comedians, or improv
actors, that have that DNA
that are figuring out
what to do on Snapchat.
I do think the filters
and all these characters
is an incredible
storytelling opportunity.
- [Voiceover] Brandon
asks, "Why are the reviews
"for VaynerMedia on
GlassDoor so bad?"
- So this one's tough for me.
There's a lot of reasons why
our reviews on
GlassDoor for VaynerMedia
are not as good
as they should be
or the reality of our culture.
I think, first of all,
I think it has a lot to do
with many different things.
First of all,
anonymous websites, right?
So you look at Secret and
Whisper and Anonymous,
you're gonna get people that
are willing to go to extremes
when nobody can figure
out who that person is.
So anonymous leads to it.
Two, we've gone from 30 to
650 people in four years.
There's a lot of pain in that,
and a lot of people that
are employees struggle
with the constant change and
the different decision making.
I move very quickly
and a lot of times
I don't do the greatest job
explaining my
actions to everybody,
and I think that creates,
you know,
I think that a lot of movement,
and a lot of structural
changes creates
a lot of angst for people
that are more comfortable
and it's easy for
the entrepreneur,
it's harder for the employees.
Three, I think cynicism is
unfortunately quite powerful,
so I think that that's the case.
I think some of the
early ones back in 2011
are just, I think I did a bad job.
I wasn't really the
active CEO of Vayner,
and I don't think we
micromanaged our youngest talent.
So I feel good, I mean I feel
bad, but good about the ones
that are in 11, I think
the last 15 of them,
and I read them all
50 times a month
are coming from employees
that I don't think
we saw the world the same way.
I mean, I don't know
what people expect
from former employees,
but if they're fired
or if they quit, they
obviously don't feel great
about the business,
and that's okay.
I mean, I think you
go look at any,
the is why I think
Yelp and GlassDoor,
and all these
anonymous sites struggle,
because what you don't have is,
I'm not gonna do
what most companies do,
which try to incentivize
their employees
to leave positive reviews to
offset the negative reviews.
That's not gonna happen.
I use them as feedback loops.
Even though we try here.
But these are people
that are not happy
with the way we're doing things.
But I think the problem
is the silent majority.
It's kind of like the Britain Exit.
I have so many
friends who are like,
I wish I voted.
I mean, you had a
chance but you didn't.
I think its politics, right?
There's a lot of people
that don't talk about
their views on, you hear it,
you look on the internet,
you see the loud minorities
dictate a narrative.
And then the
punchline is mainly,
I think everything
starts from the top,
which is I actually like having
a bad review on GlassDoor,
I think that any individual
that takes an anonymous website
of former employees,
and people say
they're current employees
that are former,
I had somebody who
I did a nice thing for,
call me and say look, I just
wanted you to know something,
when I left a bad review, this
is somebody I did something
nice for a year after
they are fired.
They called me
because they felt guilty,
and said I left a
really nasty review
because I felt that was unfair.
I was super immature,
and I also left it
as a current employee
because I thought
that would hurt you more.
So like, you know,
I think that anybody
who would stay
out of a company,
any company looking at,
Vayner what have you
because of GlassDoor or
any other anonymous site
as the proxy to what's
actually happening there,
is exactly the kind of
people that I wanna keep out.
It's the people playing
checkers versus chess,
they're so, I don't
wanna say basic minded,
because I don't
wanna razz, but like,
I don't understand how
somebody wouldn't understand
that this is an
anonymous site of people
that are the least
happy about something.
So I think there's
a lot of reasons
we have a tough review there.
They don't make me happy.
I'm really upset when people
are unhappy with things,
but I'll be honest with
you, when you're the CEO
of a company that has gone
through 1000's of employees
over the last four years, I've
has a lot more conversations
one on one with somebody
saying that they're mad at me,
or they don't like things and
they're saying it to my face,
that hurts even kind of more
because I respect them so much
for going that route.
And I wanna fix it for them.
You know, I'm in the
firefighting business.
Everything is always hard.
There's always problems.
But I'm pretty confident
about what's actually
happening here.
I think that shows
in it's results.
I think when you look at the
macro turnover rates here,
voluntary turnover
is what I look at,
we're crushing the market.
People aren't leaving
because they want, you know,
'cause they don't like it here.
And so, there's always gonna
be a percentage of people
that don't like certain things,
and I don't think I'm perfect
or this company is perfect.
Especially because we're always
making different changes.
But I know that no CEO
organization has more intent
to have people
talk to us about it.
Some people,
I look at my own father,
some people keep things inside
and will never share it,
and so I can't fix
what I don't know,
and then when it
doesn't work out,
whether on their
choice or our choice
because they kept
that poison in,
a lot of those same
people can't communicate
in real life but love
to go on anonymous site
and get that poison out.
And to be frank with you,
I actually love GlassDoor,
for A helping me not allow
people to come in
that have low EQ
and are looking at
a basic level,
and B, I'm happy that
those people are able
to get their poison of
what they feel about me
or VaynerMedia out of their body
and move on just like I
talked about in the beginning.
I hope it helps,
and I hope with that out,
they can take a step back,
look at the big picture
and maybe reach out to me and
continue our relationship.
I'm very proud of my relationship
with a lot of former employees
that left on bad terms.
And I will continue
to do that forever
because I care about my legacy.
Because I'm more selfish
about that than the money.
Than things that nature.
And by the way, you know,
as somebody who's very close
to their business,
I would say I'm 70% sure
of the exact person
that leaves that review
and there's a lot of,
I'm never confused.
You know, it just makes sense,
like sometimes
things don't go well.
Inter-people relationships
and things of that nature
and so it is what it is.
It's a challenge
because I care so much,
but if you're watching
this and you're currently
at Vayner, or you used
to be at Vayner
and you still have
negativity in you,
I'm super available.
I'm Gary at VaynerMedia,
I've always been available.
I'll always be available.
And I think that to me
is much more interesting.
You know, I'm not worried
about the perception.
GlassDoor's 2.6 rating
on VaynerMedia
isn't stopping the 1000
applications a week we're getting
or the growth of my company.
I care way more about the 20
people that are upset with me
or this, I'm here to fix it.
Forever, if there's
actually something to fix,
and even if there's not.
- [Britt] Do you
have time for one more?
- Yeah.
I felt good about that answer.
- [Voiceover] Tony says,
"Going to be deep here.
"How do you deal with people
who take advantage of you?
"You give, never take.
"Does it get lonely?"
- Yeah, I mean I think
what I tend to do.
I'm tying a lot of
these things together.
One of the reasons
I don't try to manipulate
GlassDoor like all my
friend's companies do
is it helps you
actually get the truth.
I think one of the
things that's great about
meritocracy, open ended,
not holding grudges
is that you get to see truths.
One of the things that I
think I've done quite well,
and I highly recommend
to a lot of you
is not to manipulate situations.
So by letting things
play out, you get hurt.
But because I'm so
emotionally strong,
or I like to think I am,
it gives me data.
When people hurt me
or take me for granted
or don't see the bigger picture,
I don't look at that
as a negative,
I look at it as a data point.
It allows me to decide
what opportunities I want
to give that person
if I'm in control.
Do I wanna do things
with that person
if I'm not in control.
Do I give that
person opportunities
because I am in
control in reverse.
If I think that they're
being very appreciative
or they see the big picture.
So one of the things that
I think is quite important
is not manipulating one's truth.
And so, to me, somebody
taking advantage of me
is very common.
A, I'm most comfortable in
being taken advantage of
because I like the leverage of it.
So it's a whole weird
think of my own mishegoss,
which is craziness
in Yiddish I think.
So, I've got my
own kind of thing.
I love giving.
I create environment.
I'm self aware enough
to know that I create
a lot of the beds that I make
that lead to people
taking advantage of me
because I don't create
boundaries of my giving early on
and the behavior
becomes it's like just
like anything else right.
Like you know, rich
kid, by eating too much.
By anything, discipline, if
you're not creating parameters
so I feel like I make
the bed to do that,
thus I can't be a hypocrite
and be upset about it.
The reason I like it is
I think I win twice.
One, it just feels nice.
I don't mind it, I'm good.
I'm good so I'm not scared
by people doing negative
things to me because
I'm globally good,
emotionally, forever.
Two, it's just data, I just
love watching people navigate
in a blank space.
If you don't make
too many rules,
if you don't have
too much to process,
if you do run your
company quickly,
if you do all those things,
you actually get to see
what people actually do in
real life circumstances,
not the manipulated rules
and structures and processes
that you create that
inevitably slow you down,
make you too big to change
and lead to your demise
in the game of entrepreneurship.
So, I'm very calculated
and comfortable, C-C,
calculated and
comfortable in the way
that I go businesses
and very honestly,
whether you like it or not,
whether I like it or not,
the results have spoken
for themselves.
I win, and I think that
when I look at other people
playing similar games,
they win too,
and so, you know,
how do I feel about it?
I feel like I'm thankful
that I'm in an emotional
place that allows me to be
able to eat it for breakfast,
and I think any of you that
are emotionally capable
to be taken
advantage of, should.
It's called leverage.
Yeah, good show.
I feel like that was a good
strategy going into the show,
trying to level them up, right?
- [Britt] I liked it.
- You liked it?
DRock?
OT?
Staphon?
Haris, Horace, Haris?
- [Haris] Phenomenal.
- Awesome.
Question of the day.
Tell me about your most
positive work experience.
I think we always talk
about what's wrong.
I'm gonna start really like right?
Tell me like, why can't
we read the comments
and all get excited,
learn from that.
We can learn from the positive.
I'm just tired of
cynicism and negativity.
The political climate,
like the world climate,
like just you know, there's
so much good going on.
You know how much good
so many of you had
over the last 72 hours?
Like there so much good
things to be thankful for.
Tell me about your most
positive work experience.
In detail, tag people that
did nice things for you.
Chauncey Billups,
the basketball player,
just wrote an article
in Player's Tribune
and gave dabs to Tyrell Brandon.
It was awesome, it was
awesome to see an athlete
be like this guy put me
on when he got injured.
You never hear that.
You always hear like the
documentary with like,
and the star player
got injured and,
even though he was trying
to suppress the kid,
the kid got his chance and won.
So he put me
on in the right way,
we need to be pushing optimism
and positivity some more,
because that's really what works.
So tell me about your in detail,
tag the person that
deserves the love
about your most
positive work experience.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering.